each time Tarkin Kornel shows people
around his neighborhood Belu something
has changed every week stores bars and
galleries disappear right here is where
one of Baylor's most popular rock bars
used to be it vanished overnight instead
of these old and very popular nightclubs
we'll be seeing stores with cheap goods
and shady businesses like illegal
nightclubs the district of Baillieu is
proud of its centerpiece the galata
tower in the past few years this
neighborhood which used to be filled
with Christian and Jewish minorities has
become one of Istanbul popular cultural
attractions but the once famous cultural
theme is also slowly disappearing more
and more artists and foreigners are
leaving they Alou art galleries movie
theaters bars and event venues are
closing since the terrorist attacks last
year one actually in the middle of
Bengal ooh and the attempted coup
visitors have stopped coming on top of
that the value of the Turkish lira is
plummeting these days the Turks have
less money for entertainment and there
are fewer tourists at least once from
the West instead more travelers from
Arab countries are stopping by but the
people who live in Baillieu say these
guests would rather smoke a water pipe
then go to a jazz concert or drink a
glass of beer
ever since the tourists have become
mainland Arabic many of the bars have
been forced to close the owners can't
afford to buy rent anymore on this
corner alone seven shops have shut down
this closed gallery is a symbol of the
slow decline of this traditional
neighborhood and many see it as a
portent of what may lay ahead for Turkey
if the country does not regain political
and
stability and even in Tarkin canora's
bar nothing is going on
but Kohinoor doesn't want to give up
he's lived in Baillieu nearly his entire
life yet sometimes he can sympathize
with how his guests feel there's always
this danger of terror warnings against
crowds and a harsh manner the police use
against the demonstrations that often go
through all this leaves the people
having less of a thirst for
entertainment yes optimist they Istanbul
will bounce back it has withstood more
than one crisis but pessimists doubt
that Istanbul will ever again be as
colorful and international as Baillieu
or rather as Baillieu used to be